Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Eh,
what's going on?
Just checking in on you and I know what all you conscious.
Ooh,
fucking Friday.
What did she call it?
Stick it up.
Your fucking mom blogs over their podcast.
I'll tell you why.
All right.
Make you all feel guilty.
I didn't do it yesterday cause I was at a funeral.
Alright,
you self centered cons.
Uh,
but now I'm back.
I'm back and I'm checking in on you.
You been any it on and even more fun day and I know what you think of.
Well Bill,
why didn't you do it even earlier,
earlier,
Friday morning?
The funeral was yesterday.
Well I just did a four hour tour on the,
uh,
the radio promoting my,
um,
my run through a the Midwest.
All right,
I'm going to be in Fort Wayne,
Dayton,
Cincinnati.
It's like a Johnny Cash song.
I began to Fort Wayne [inaudible].
She touched Louise,
the name of our town.
I love this guy.
Um,
Columbus,
Cleveland,
grand rapids,
Milwaukee,
Minneapolis,
Chicago.
I'm Pittsburgh.
I'm sure I forgot something else.
So,
uh,
we'll bring in our fucking comedy all the way through.
They're all right.
There you go.
So that's why.
So now,
whatever,
it's Friday and uh,
I got some shit to talk about it then,
then I got to,
you don't want me fucked up.
You know when you get the thing,
you know,
you get the registration every year for your car and then you get the little
sticker to put on your plate.
I'm usually so good about that.
I can't find the fucking stickers.
And today's the day to day is the cradle it,
today's the day after today,
I'll get a fucking,
oh,
I hasn't have to have it on today or I'll get a fucking ticket.
So,
uh,
ah,
Jesus,
if I gotta go back down to the fucking TMV I know it's somewhere under that
mountain of shit on my,
my,
my desk right now.
Did you guys have used to read that fucking
comic strip about that fat bird shoe?
Boom.
Mumord his desk looked like that's what my desk looks like right now.
So I got a Wa I gotta get that fixed.
You guys check that out,
that fucking cartoon check comic Strip from newspapers that nobody even fucking
reads anymore.
It's good.
That's,
that's a nice,
that's a nice visual.
You know when you were in a visual medium bill,
it's always good to bring up a comic strip from 30 fucking years ago.
Sorry,
I'm a little grumpy from a little grumpy from flying here.
Um,
oh.
Speaking of flying,
right.
So I flew to Chicago and then had to get on a puddle jumper,
um,
for the funeral.
And uh,
I was sitting next to this guy,
he had a hat on that said,
I love Jesus.
He had on Pete Carroll,
Khakis is old guy,
thin as a rail.
And he was reading this religious book and I swear to God he was underlining
almost every fucking sentence.
And then he was writing shit down next to me.
Right.
We'll like shoulder to shoulder and this little,
uh,
this little puddle jumper.
Hang on,
hang on one second.
What's the matter?
You got to ask me something.
I'll hit pause.
Hold on.
Hang on.
The lovely Nia.
Hold on.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
I really wish I recorded that because I actually was right for once.
Um,
anyways,
so anyways,
the guys get to Pete Carroll,
fucking dark is on thin Israelis underlying this religious thing.
Okay.
And I'm just sitting there.
The old me would be like,
we'll all JJ,
as you know,
this guy with his religion.
I was actually sitting there going,
you know what?
I bet he's a great guy.
I mean,
he's a decent human being and a,
this keeps him,
keeps him that way.
So God bless him.
And right as I had that positive thought,
all of a sudden this fucking guy,
I know it was him.
I don't know it was him,
but I'm pretty sure it was him.
He just fucking just lets this old man Fargo,
yeah.
Dead.
It just smells like,
just imagine farting in an attic is the only way.
The only way to describe it.
It was like moth balls,
old toys [inaudible] greatest generation fart.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
Like I didn't even try to hide it.
I just put I s I literally said,
Oh my God.
And I put my shirt over my nose.
Right.
Okay.
In a fucking goes away.
He doesn't even address,
this is a 50 minute fucking flight.
All right?
We're going up.
We're coming right back down.
It's like we're going to Vegas,
except I'm going to a funeral,
so it's not a fucking fun time.
And this fucking guy,
all right.
Right.
As we reached cruising altitude,
he does it again.
He rips another one.
Okay.
And I'm like,
I'm staring at the side of his head and I know we can feel me and he won't
fucking look at him and he's still underlining all this,
you know,
fucking Jesus Shit.
And I like that.
You gotta be fucking kidding,
Dude.
It was ungodly.
Okay.
Hard boiled eggs in a fucking outhouse.
All right?
It was fucking horrific.
Okay.
And I know it was him,
you know,
I know it was him because the smell was so fucking bad and he was sitting and
not reacting to shit.
All right.
I don't know if he was turning the other cheek,
some religious shit,
no pun intended there.
I don't know what the fuck he was doing,
but I am 99% sure that it was him and I'm like,
what the fuck to her,
this would be unacceptable in a cross country flight,
New York to La.
This guy has done this on a puddle jumper.
50 minute flight.
Okay.
Leaving Chicago.
Right.
Then we started to descend and this motherfucker.
Yeah,
three fucking times and at this point,
50 minutes now I got to Fart and I'm like,
God,
you want,
you want to fucking play?
Oh Man.
Do you want to dance?
I'm ready to fucking rip two bike.
I couldn't get myself to do it cause I'm like,
what if?
What if it is in him?
What if he's so fucking old?
He can't smell anything anymore.
Oh my God.
It had to have been him because the people in front of me,
a young dude,
this fucking guy,
man,
Jesus Christ,
Jesus fucking Christ,
this guy like
three times in a 50 minute fucking flight.
Do you know what that reminded me of?
I remember this guy one time,
I did this showcase down at the comedy store to do,
be able to do a half hour on showtime or HBO was huge.
This was like 12 years ago,
and I'm living in New York and I'm like,
oh my God,
this is it.
This is getting a make or break me.
So it's a fucking showcase.
All right?
First of all,
I got to fly myself out there.
So already I'm out of pocket already.
This is something that I totally won and now I'm out of pocket.
I got to pay for this fucking plane ticket.
I had to cancel money gigs and I fly out to do this fucking thing.
I've got to put myself up,
get the rental car,
the whole fucking thing,
hemorrhaging cash.
But this is big pot of gold at the end of the rainbow,
right?
So it's down at the comedy store in the early two thousands and I fucking show
up and this like fucking five people in the crowd.
All right?
There was two white people and then there was this black guy sitting in between
these two white girls,
and I go on first,
I fucking go up there and I'm up there and the whole time up there,
the black guy is talking to the two white girls and they laugh and,
and Blah,
blah,
blah.
So you know,
I'm addressing it.
I'm addressing it going,
Oh,
this is great,
man.
Flew all the way across the country to do a half hour in front of five people.
How I did a few more jokes,
little bits of laughter.
I'm just addressing what's going on,
right?
So I get off completely like,
yeah,
Jesus Christ,
like this is fucking rhythm.
It's not,
it's not even a fucking showcase.
Who's fucking bullshit is what it was.
I go to the back and I stand out a little hallway and the guy running the thing
comes out to me,
all right,
the big shot running the thing and he just goes,
he goes seven times,
said,
this is how it remind me of the far thing.
When I said three times in a 50 minute flight,
this guy fired.
This guy goes to me cause seven times,
seven times and a and had whatever it was,
10 minutes said 15 minutes set,
whatever the fuck I had to do.
I can say it didn't have to do the whole half hour.
I probably just had to do with shit.
It's a showcase,
right?
Yeah.
Probably like 10 15 minutes.
He could seven times.
He did 15 minutes set.
You addressed how few people were in the crowd,
you know you say that enough time,
the people in the crowd like,
yeah,
I mean what are we doing here and they're going to leave.
It's like we're in the back.
We can hear the material.
Who?
Blue,
blue,
blue and he's just fucking sitting and I'm just looking at the guy and he goes,
don't worry,
don't worry.
He goes,
she's still in the running.
You still in the running to get a special and that's what I wanted to grab him
by the throat and rip out his fucking voicebox.
Do you mean I'm still in the running you fat con?
Do you think I'm fucking stand in here.
Wait for you to tap me on the head with your magic wand.
You can make it now.
Sprinkle your little fairy dust on me.
Oh,
now I'm valid.
You stupid cunt.
This is your fucking showcase.
You fucked up.
You should have packed the fucking room.
Aren't supposed to do stand up in front of five.
Fuck,
I wish I said that,
but I did.
I just sat there and took it the same way I took it from that fucking old man.
I don't give a shit if he fought in world war two,
if he wasn't on the front fucking lines with a flame thrower,
fuck him.
Okay.
Fucking people into Jesus.
Is that what Jesus teaches you the fucking far three times on a 50 minute puddle
jumper and not even address it?
You was fucking funny to.
The air is pressurized to it's a lot fucking thinner when you're up there,
right?
So I bet I was spreading out even further.
Wasn't all packed in,
you know,
you're fart.
You're fired if fucking sea level.
You know what I mean?
You got a little
there.
The little more compact,
right?
I might be off here,
but you know that you don't think when you have an empty water bottle with the
cap on it,
right?
As you start to descend,
it starts to implode,
right?
Cause cause the air and the outside is more fucking dance.
It's got to fill up that space.
So this guy farted like inside that fucking dead fucking bottled water.
Empty bottle of water.
Okay.
Nothing but open fucking lanes.
Oh God.
It's so fucking gross.
Do you realize when you're smelling somebody far that was air that was trapped
in there?
Fucking guts.
That's what the fuck.
And now it's in you.
It's in you.
It went into your bloodstream and it's fuel in your fucking body and going up to
your brain.
This fucking guy's Korean wharf,
Korean conflict farts three fucking times.
And every time I'd look at him like,
what the fuck I'd see on the corner of was on the corner of his brill.
It said,
I love Jesus.
Okay,
What do I know?
Fucking farden.
Here you go.
Go.
Oh my God.
You know,
I actually wanted to do,
I wanted to reach down and pretend like I was going to tie my shoes like in
Schwartzenegger in a raw deal when he elbowed dead fucking black dude and they
put the fucking Panama Jack Hat on his head.
Dante interrupt my friend,
he's dead tired.
You don't remember that.
Then he climbed down the landing gear.
I would have done that.
Landed right and fucking Lake Michigan.
You know,
I don't give a fuck hypothermia.
Then I sink to the bottom.
Michigan doesn't give up its dead Lake Michigan does not give up.
It's dead.
You go down.
That's it.
They never see again.
But you don't get eaten by a shark.
You just sorta teeth chatter for awhile.
Then you get that warm,
peaceful feeling,
you know
and you wish like,
oh,
you know,
maybe I didn't kill that.
I love Jesus guy.
Wish I read that book and I had that hat and I had those fucking pants on and
that's stupid old man jacket he had.
God knows he's going to go to the pearly gates he's getting in second.
He walks in.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
he probably has like a fucking
lining at Jack was probably made out of some fucking big girls back skin.
Right.
Some fucking serial killer.
Maybe that's what I was smelling.
We're going to fucking body partners.
God Damn fucking suck.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm back from the Midwest.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
My uncle passed away as I match of what of what a great guy man.
What an absolute,
so it was weird.
It's one of those funerals that was sad and uplifting because you knew the guy
lived a great life,
but everyone was so sad that we weren't going to see him again.
And a and enough time had passed between me sit next to the Guy Fart in his
fucking brains out.
Maybe he's so old.
He couldn't control it and he was embarrassed,
you know,
when he had like those depends on,
I know he didn't shoot himself if he shit himself,
like the fucking goddamn windows would have blown out on the thing.
So anyway,
so let's,
let's get on with the Thursday.
How's your week going?
That's how my week was going,
you know.
Um,
okay.
I'm getting ready to do this fucking tour,
get some acting work next week and I can't find the stickers to put on my
license plate.
So,
uh,
we've got a lot of bullshit going on.
But,
uh,
you know what I did get a chance to do when I was flying back,
I got to watch the uh,
the Astros and the royals series.
Um,
it's always hard to tell in the first game when it's going to be like,
cause somebody is usually bring it.
There's usually one unhittable fucking guy.
Right?
And you have no idea.
But you know what was great was Fox sports,
they got Pete rose doing the analysis.
He was fucking crushing it.
Just totally be in Pete rose.
He's like the guy I met when I ever tell you guys that story when I had him a
sign,
those photos,
you know,
he,
he's usually,
it's Caesar's.
Any sides.
Right.
And I was with La head and I was like,
fuck man,
it's greatest hitter of all time.
Right.
And how much does he wish that he created?
Draft Kings or fan duel,
you know,
awesome.
That would be,
and then he became a fucking billionaire.
Unbelievable.
You know how fan duel and draft kings are fucking up right now?
If they just admitted that they were gambling,
the whole thing would go away.
Other than that,
there's no story.
That stupid scandal where they go,
they had inside information and people,
he'd fucking draft kings gambled,
true fan duel and made hundreds of thousands of dollars.
What insight information could you have?
Did they pay off a referee?
How do you get inside information?
Are they talking to somebody there or who plays in a league?
Some quarterback for some team,
they pay him off to win a couple hundred grand.
Doesn't make any.
If they didn't have any fucking inside information,
there's no fucking way they did.
They didn't.
They just had the decency to not gamble within their own site.
They went to another one and they fucking one.
That's all right.
I saw the guy who runs draftkings.
He was on TV trying to explain why draft kings is a game of skill versus betting
against the line.
He goes,
well,
if you bet against the line,
it's 50 50 you know you either win or you lose.
It's like it's not 50 50 have you ever gambled in your life?
You bet against the spread.
You loose,
you can win that week.
But if it's 50 50 why would there even be a sports book?
So we keep handing back the same fucking hundred bucks over and over again.
And then he was like,
Whoa,
this thing,
you know,
if,
if you just go pick a bunch of players,
you don't know what you're doing.
Someone who has better skill than you will win every time.
Like that's the loophole,
which is fucking true.
But it's still gambling because in the end it's like,
yeah.
And then when I lose to that guy,
I lose money because I wage heard that I was going to be better than them.
What an all comes down to is why they gave me shit and why they stopped
advertising on here is they didn't want me to call it gambling even though they
knew it was fucking gambling because they fucking want to stay in business with
the leaks.
And the leagues,
the fucking whores that they are,
are trying to scoop up all this easy fucking money through gambling as they brow
beat their own fucking players about it,
that we know,
which,
whatever.
I mean that's,
that's the American fucker.
It's actually the human way.
But to sit there has to be,
to be as transparent assistance.
It's just obviously be what the fuck it is.
And this,
they sit there and be an apple and sit there.
But yeah,
no,
I'm a,
I'm a fucking banana.
You're not,
none of it's,
it's,
I'm,
I'm not a fruit.
I'm a banana.
Apple,
you know,
you just,
you use can bite right into it and you're right to the fruit,
a banana,
you got to appeal it,
the fruits on the inside.
So it's,
it's,
it's not a fruit.
Um,
you know,
I really think the biggest problem with fan duel and draft kings is that they,
uh,
the young people that all of us that came up with this thing,
and now both those companies are worth $1 billion each.
And I think this is so young and so came out of nowhere that they didn't know
what palms to Greece when you're in a national gambling site,
you know what I mean?
There's all kinds of fucking town cars that have to pull up and you gotta be
handing them a little packages of fucking money and blah blah blah blah blah.
So everybody will look the uh,
the fucking way,
you know what I mean?
Cause his bad is what fan duel and draft kings are doing.
What the,
what those fucking cancer awareness people are doing.
All right.
And people that get in bed with them and they sell it to you as though by this
pink Jersey and all the money from this,
the,
when they say a portion,
I mean you,
you think more money than not,
it's going to go towards actual cancer victims.
Right.
Then you find out it's like fucking 8% and then that 8% goes to the pink,
right?
And then she's got to make her 650 grand a fucking year and they got all their
infrastructure and it all trickles.
It's not even research,
it's just awareness.
The whole fucking thing is perverted.
So I don't know.
I still don't think it's as bad as what the pink ladies still with.
But I'll tell you right now,
the NFL man,
the walls are closing in.
You've got that pink horse shit going on.
On one side.
You're in bed with the sports book,
right?
And nobody say shit.
Nobody's saying shit because you make ESPN so much fucking money and ESPN is
going to sit there.
What are they going to talk about Tom Brady and fucking air pressure.
All right,
I'd beaten that to fucking death.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Who would know better about hypocrisy?
That a fucking hypocrite like me.
Um,
how far into this?
All right,
let's read a little bit of advertising here.
Um,
the little that I have left,
the little that I have left on this show,
I have to hum my password.
I fuck it up.
There we go.
All right.
By the way,
is anybody wants to that show?
Uh Oh wait,
I forgot the Pete rose story.
Sorry.
Let me get back to the Pete rose story.
Like three old guys just went
thought he was going to forget it.
Um,
all right.
The Pete Rose Story.
So he signing in Vegas,
Mila,
they were like,
that's the greatest hitter of all time.
We got to go talk to the guy.
So it works as you got to buy something that he then signs and then we'll
fucking talk to you.
Fair enough.
You've got 4,100 more hits than I do.
Apps a fucking lowly,
let's do it.
Right.
Um,
or whatever the fuck he has.
So there's two fucking,
almost identical pictures from the 1975 1976 world series with the big red
machine.
Went back to back titles.
They beat the red sox is seven games and then they beat the Yankees in four
games.
And both of them,
like anybody who watched Pete rose play in his hay day,
the classic of him is him rounding second base.
His batting helmet flies off and then he dives headfirst into third base.
So the two photos,
one was of him doing it against the red sox.
Helmut was already live.
He's like superman in the air.
Diving in safely for a triple or whatever,
or first to third on a single to write.
God knows Charlie Hustle probably did that.
What?
I don't know what it is.
All he know,
he's sliding into third safely.
The Yankees won same thing,
helmet off,
diving in through the air,
going to be safe.
So I said,
hey man,
I'm a red sox fan.
I got the red sox and the Yankees won.
I go,
I'm on the red sox won.
Can you write bill?
I'm sorry,
Pete rose.
And he immediately just looked up at me with that fucking game seven look in his
eyes when I said,
can you say I'm sorry.
He just looked at me and he goes,
I'm not,
and I laughed and he still wrote it.
And then when I wrote,
I told him to write on the Yankees won to write bill,
you're welcome.
Then he laughed and he understood the joke and then we started,
we actually got to talk to him a little bit and uh,
that nobody likes talking baseball,
like a guy like that,
man.
I mean to be able to hit the way that guy fucking hit you are literally an
encyclopedia.
Him,
Tony Gwynn,
Ted Williams,
Wade Boggs,
all the great hitters of all time.
That's what kills me about each year.
Oh Man.
Like I wish I can understand the guy better cause I would love to listen to
that.
Like to me it's Badass is,
is hitting a home run.
Hitting for fucking average is the coolest fucking thing ever.
You know what I mean?
Those big guys that fucking hit home runs and everybody stands on the same side
of the field because they know we can't do anything else other than,
than pull the fucking ball.
You know?
I like those guys sprayed all over the fucking field.
Um,
like they're like,
they're like the porn stars
of hitters,
right?
Just fucking spray sprayed all over the place.
So anyways,
we actually got to talk to them about,
I'm like,
you know,
who's the toughest guy you've ever had to pitch against?
And he actually asked us to guess because it's the same time,
you know,
he's,
he's just like,
well,
I'm not going to tell his fucking story again.
You know,
when I have a little fun with this,
let me test you baseball knowledge.
So we were trying to think of everybody.
We like,
uh,
Don Drysdale,
Nolan Ryan,
uh,
fucking uh,
what's his face?
Tom See,
oh,
I guess the guy,
uh,
fuck's his name from Saint Louis,
Bob Gibson.
And he was like,
nope,
nope.
Went through the whole fucking thing and be like,
who?
And he said,
Sandy Kofax.
And we like,
really?
And he goes,
Oh yeah man.
He goes,
his curve ball and then he,
he just imitated the flight of the ball and he hadn't basically almost on like
an arch and then just fucking,
just,
just dropping off the table.
And he did it like on both sides.
Like it was like,
it didn't matter if you will,
right handed or left handed.
And Pete was a switch hitter,
if I remember correctly.
It's like,
it didn't matter what side of the plate he stood on.
The shit came in like it was in your fucking wheel house and then it just
fucking disappeared.
So,
um,
as much as I know,
anytime I cannot watch ESPN just to give somebody else a chance,
even though Fox is fucking huge.
It's not like there's some mom and pop,
I'll do it,
but I love that he's on there.
Um,
even though they got that big weird dragnet looking guy who's just going like,
hello people,
this is a TV show.
He does like that type of humor.
It's like,
you know,
God,
he looks like a fucking,
he looks like a,
a beat cop from like 1955.
He should be outside Ebbets field.
Um,
just really loud.
That's like those two guys that come on and the camera's fucking move in.
Like,
oh,
something exciting is happening.
We got,
we got to be beyond the highlights.
Everybody,
we've got to put her own stamps on the sports shelf that doing that fucking
thing.
So,
um,
I dunno,
or at least comes on late and I'm like halfway pass it out and they're fucking
screaming and yelling
like Trey Wingo at his worst.
You know,
Trey Wingo has got Sarah fucking sound in his voice.
We just like,
dude,
you're relaxed.
You're not playing.
Just,
just read the fucking highlights for you.
Um,
or whatever the fuck it is.
You do not read the highlights.
What is,
what is,
is it that they do?
What is it that I do?
Well,
what does anybody fucking though?
Um,
Oh,
before I do the advertising here,
I got to go off on this fucking thing.
Uh,
my wife has gotten me to start watching that shark tank thing and uh,
I fucking hate that show.
All right.
And He'd have these young,
fresh faced kids come in and these fucking jerk offs act like they're the
biggest geniuses ever.
You know what I mean?
They're all billionaires,
right?
They in then just the shit that they say is so fucking evil,
you know?
First of all,
Mark Cuban's sits there and it looks like the not shark tank.
I was joking.
I go,
this looks like drunk tank.
The Guy fucking sits there and when he's listening,
he's slouching and he's got that fucking a full metal jacket.
I am in a world of Shit.
He like looks up to his eyebrows and his mouth is like half open.
Um,
although it's funny,
I love how heartless they are where they're just like,
okay,
this is a security thing.
And he goes,
what's your background in security?
He goes,
oh,
I don't have a background.
And he just goes,
I'm out.
I love when they do shit like that.
But the,
uh,
the bald con there when he goes,
um,
these two fresh face girls come on,
right?
And uh,
they come on and they say that the,
I don't know what the fuck they make it,
but all I know is whatever they're making cost four bucks,
that's what they sell it for.
And it costs $3 to make it.
And then baldy comes in.
He's like,
oh,
hey,
well,
let me know how do we get it?
$1,
make it for $1 and then I get three fucking dollars,
you know,
and they put that pressure on the kids and that right there is how fucking
factories leave this country.
And you've got some crying eight year old making it for fucking 2 cents,
that God damn month that.
And also unions totally took advantage of their position.
We're miserable.
Cons to fucking have to deal with both of those things.
So I don't like,
I don't like the whole fucking thing.
Hey,
we're going to come up with a great idea and a,
you're going to fucking buy in and basically own the thing in the,
the whole,
the shark tank,
like,
like they're not on some level,
reprehensible human beings taking advantage of fresh faced kids.
You know,
I really oversimplified all of that.
And you know what?
I love that I did very little information,
very poor business background.
You know,
Mark Cuban's my favorite part on the show,
just w I don't know what his resting faces,
but uh,
I can't believe he's not going,
Eh,
when he's sitting there,
cause that's what his face looks like.
Um,
all right,
so let's read some advertising.
Uh,
all right,
blue apron,
everybody.
Blue Apron.
How much is the apron?
How much?
How can we make it
be fucking 2 cents to make the apron and then I,
I get eh,
Eh,
I get all of the rest of it.
All right.
Blue Apron.
It's okay.
You can admit it.
The last thing anybody wants to do after work is wait in line at the grocery
store,
Schlep home and cook a complicated meal and expensive,
unhealthy takeout is hardly better.
Tell me about it.
And I was on the road.
I ate steak and shake.
Oh,
Billy is going in the wrong direction.
I could have turned this around.
Maybe I should use blue apron.
That's where the new servers,
blue apron comes in.
Yeah.
If you come home and you're tired and you sat next to some old guy fart and next
to you for the whole time,
you're going to end up at steak and shake.
Right?
But who wants to do that?
Then you stare at your white alabaster freckle belly the next morning and you're
actually contemplate doing a sailor dive right on into the fucking scale.
If you want to avoid that,
go to blue apron.
Blue Apron delivers farm fresh ingredients and step by step recipes to your
home.
By the way,
sailor dive is when you jump in headfirst with your hands to your sides.
That's what I was taught down at the pool.
Um,
allowing you to back when they actually had deep ends in pools,
allowing you to create healthy handcrafted meals at home without going to the
grocery store.
Now it's just like deep enough or your man tits there under the surface for less
than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron sends you fresh ingredients,
perfectly proportioned,
making,
cooking healthy meals,
really easy and fun.
No trips to the grocery store and no waste from unused ingredients.
Plus you'll learn to cook with special ingredients.
Specialty ingredients accuse me that are normally hard to find.
Blue Apron is perfect.
It's perfect for date night cooking with friends and they even offer family
plants with kid friendly ingredients so the whole family can eat well and have
fun preparing the meals together.
Each balanced meal is 500 to 700 calories per serving and so tasty.
You'd never know.
Cooking takes half an hour.
Shipping is flexible and free and the menus are always knew they won't send the
same meal twice.
They work around your schedule and dietary preferences and blue apron experts
source only the best seasonal ingredients for incredible meals like Parmesan
crusted chicken with roasted heirloom potatoes and tomato [inaudible] salad and
10 dory spice chicken with green lentils is,
fuck it sounds delicious.
I don't even know what that is.
Oh wait.
Don't jump on the mix of Buddy eggplant and cucumber mint yogurt.
You'll cook incredible meals and be blown away by the quality and freshness.
Blue Apron.
It's a better way to cook.
Check out this week's menu and get your first two meals for free by going to
blue apron.com/burr my treat really the first two.
What's their treat?
Really the first two meals are on me when you go to blue apron.com/birth all
right,
we've got somebody new here.
We've got somebody new here.
Um,
club w club w don't you hate when wine looks like it's a 10 but winds
up tasting like a six a that's what he said.
Huh?
Away or even worse when you walk into the store to pick out your wine,
you could easily be fooled into a situation just like this.
Well,
there's an,
there's this new wine club called Club dubby club.
Dubby tear to find tear.
They change everything.
No more full,
no more being fooled by winds that pretend to be hotter or tastier than they
actually are.
It's easy.
You Go to club w.
Dot com and answer six simple questions their algorithm creates,
I can't believe I said that right.
Their algorithm creates a palate profile just for you.
Then they send wine directly to your door,
perfectly customized to match your tastes.
Club w is the leak is leading the grape to glass wine revolution.
They worked directly with vineyards to cut out the middleman,
which saves you money.
So with club Debbie five and tear,
uh,
you get premium wine customized to your taste and a third of what you would pay
at the store.
They even have a no risk,
a hundred percent guarantee that you'll love what they send you.
And right now clip Debbie buying land.
It sits on an aquifer because the population controls out of control.
The populations out of control I'll get better at this,
is offering my listeners 50% off your first order when they go to club.
Debbie,
we're looking for weapons of mass destruction dotcom slash.
Berg.
So stop wasting time and money messing around at retail stores and start
drinking wine.
You know,
you're going to love.
Just go to club Debbie,
fool me once.
You're not going to fool me again.
Uh,
just go to club w.
Dot com slash Berg at 50% off your first order.
That's club debbie.com and I'm just going to be toast club w.com/.
Bar.
That's actually great man.
Because you know something like at this point,
like literally like the guy who directed after like a back to school has,
has his own wine.
You know what I mean?
The best wine that I ever had is a,
is a Barolo and a not the one that's more acidic.
It's more the,
the fruity or one.
And um,
if you get a great bottle of the lab as for a Barola,
that's what I can tell you.
Or you can go to blue apron.
Tell,
tell him that you like a Barolo when you go to club Debbie Club W.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
let's,
let's finish up this podcast here.
Um,
where am I going here?
Oh,
let's talk hockey.
Hockey just started,
right?
Hockey just started an hour.
Hey,
how about Rafi Torres setting the tone early.
Jesus Christ.
I wonder if they did that on um,
PTI.
The best thing on ESPN.
I want to,
if they did,
happy Torah,
epic tours,
happy trails to Rafi Torres.
Jesus Christ.
Did he think because he glided the last 40 feet that he,
that,
that wasn't like 14 strides when he knocked that dude out.
Um,
if you guys don't like Rafi Torres,
watch Adam McQuade first,
Rafi Torres,
he handled his fucking business against that guy.
Um,
and if you want to listen to somebody go off on Rafi Torres,
listened to Joe Barton Ix.
Puck off.
I'm sure he had an epic rant on him.
And um,
oh,
I wanted to talk about end zone celebrations when I put the,
put it,
put it on.
I guess I don't hate ESPN because I like watching Steven A.
Smith and uh,
uh,
what the fuck's his name there?
Willie.
The Wipper.
What the fuck's his name there?
Ah,
fuck.
It's a little tick game show host name.
Great head of hair.
The fuck's his name?
Yeah.
Well I can think of,
is Chuck Light Dell?
I know it's not that.
What the fuck is his name?
Steven.
A Smith and
it's like,
whoa.
Wipie it's one of those fucking thing.
Yahoo one of those fucking names.
Take some yell on a rollercoaster,
but you don't,
if you would draw on it,
you would.
Anyway.
So we're talking about end zone celebrations and Steve,
Steven A.
Smith was dancing around the fact that that,
that there's a cultural racial race thing underneath there and a control by the
NFL.
And uh,
the other fucking guy there,
I zippity Doo Dah,
whatever his fucking name is,
was saying that it wasn't,
and I think at 100% is 100% is all right when it comes to white and black people
like white people,
like when you score a touchdown,
you supposed to act like an astronaut and be like,
well,
ah,
I had a lot of help that now this is one small step.
Provide team loud giant step for everybody else.
That's what you supposed to do,
Eh,
uh,
generally speaking,
black people more look at it like,
yeah,
I did that shit.
Fuck you.
I'm unstoppable.
Right?
That's the opposite ends of the spectrum,
which I think if there was more white people that were unstoppable in sports,
the white people that ran the league would have less problem with the end zone
dancing.
That's,
I mean I'm over simplifying the whole fucking thing.
But uh,
you know,
that is,
that is kind of a cultural difference where it's socially acceptable or the
African American community that if you are the shit to say that you are the
shit.
If for some reason in the white community you supposed to tone it down,
even if you are the shit he supposed to be humble.
And I,
what I think that really comes from is the opera 1% of white people that take
all the fucking money,
you know what I mean?
And back in the day they were celebrities,
the Rockefellers,
the Vanderbilts,
the Astors,
you knew what they fucking look like and they had all the money and all the
resentment went their way.
So they are like,
well,
we got to pull back.
Here we go.
We've got to stop the end zone dancing coming down the street with their fucking
top hats.
And Shit,
we gotta be a little more humble so nobody comes over to our house and takes all
our shit.
Right.
So then they came up with corporations,
right?
And they could hit and those things and then they came up with the whole,
yeah,
the family sold it off to this corporation.
We don't have the money that we'll use to have,
you know,
the Rockefellers and all of those fucking people.
And I think that that's just sort of filters down,
you know,
where if you're,
if you're running shit,
you,
you're,
you want to like,
ah,
that didn't make any sense,
did it?
But I definitely,
I think there's definitely some race they get in there,
you know what I mean?
I think it is,
you know,
and it's also a time issue too.
What I mean,
like if a white person sings the national anthem has hackey is this is,
you know,
it's going to be over and fucking,
basically about what a minute 58 seconds is even take that long.
Right.
And then you're going to be able to go to commercial and sell your Fritos.
All right.
Generally speaking,
you don't have somebody black come say,
hey,
you know,
you might have to cut a couple of commercials.
Whoa.
Hey.
Right.
You know,
it's going to be that we're a white guy.
He's just going to get out there and I go,
oh shea,
he's already to the se,
right.
He gets their fucking two thirds of the time quicker.
Alrighty.
There you go.
That's me checking in on you.
Um,
you,
I hope you have a great weekend and uh,
everybody's been freaking out about the musical interludes here.
This is a all Andrew feminists.
Um,
he's a younger fella,
so he knows all the hip new stuff.
If I was doing it,
it would be like a tie,
a yellow ribbon round the old oak tree.
That's been three y'all gears.
This is the music of linear though.
Dead yet.
Still Watch still on me.
If I don't see that ribbon round at old oak tree,
I'll get on the bus.
Forget about us.
Put the blame off
Tony,
Orlando,
everybody.
If you want to put that on your little iPods,
listen to it.
Ironically,
I don't,
I listen to it emotionally and I cry and think about how old I am.
Go fuck yourselves a see on Monday.
Enjoy it the second half of the Thursday afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast that came out on Friday.
All
right.
Hi Bill.
How are you?
Um,
I'm a big fan out of Edmonton,
Alberta,
Canada.
I've been up there Northlands call the same,
the greatest hockey team on the greatest thing was going to say,
I've heard you talk about it in regards to hockey.
Edmonds.
Uh,
okay.
You got fans up here.
So pull a Louis CK and come up.
Uh,
I guess Louie was just up there.
some good food,
some good beer that you no longer drink in some women that I feel put Montreal
the shame.
Oh Shit.
I liked that.
Huh?
I liked the ladies.
Need some advice and if you felt like bringing in the lovely Nia lady,
uh,
then by all means do so as a woman's thoughts would be very welcomed.
All right,
here we go.
My fiancee,
my fiancee,
my fiance
from Virginia told me recently that one of her fantasies as a threesome with
another lady,
a thing is whenever I bring it up,
she gets squeamish about it.
I've come across two separate women that have said they're interested in her as
an I is a couple,
but when it was time to meet my fight,
my fiance pretty much said she didn't want to once was due to my fiance being
three months pregnant
with our authors horn.
We don't judge on the podcast.
Even so you know you're not a dirt bag.
That's actually really hilarious,
but how inappropriate would it be to have a,
well,
I'm sure people who have done,
I wonder how that would damage the kid is damaged.
The kid,
the kid is in there and he can hear like,
you know,
maybe the kid would become a porn star.
You never seen that day when people read books to the womb
and the kid comes out and all of a sudden he can do calculus,
calculus,
you never seen that.
You'll be a play music to the kid.
He comes out,
he's like fucking Moza wait a minute.
Babies.
Not that anyway,
just keep reading.
Just keep reading.
What's it like a little tadpole in there.
Just can't understand it.
It's not going to be affected by a three,
seven.
Is that what it looks like a peer during her three months
being pregnant.
That's when the baby,
the baby looks like a little t rex within one of those fucking alien heads.
All right.
Once it was due to my fiance being three months pregnant with our first born and
the second time was because I had a crush on said woman.
Well Jesus Christ,
give me self a dog in the fight sir.
Um,
so what gives?
This guy's a moron.
I don't get what's going on.
Wow.
Fond of girl,
girl pro porn when she rubs one out.
Makes comments when we're in public about other women being attractive sexually.
So she portrays herself as into them,
yet she doesn't pursue her.
Suppose it fantasy and when I bring it up she seems put off about the whole
thing.
Should I keep trying to make it happen or just throwing the towel?
Oh yeah,
cause it's going really good so far.
Hey,
we give help during
the advice section and she's most likely doing it cause your methods are
obviously amazing and she's most likely saying,
well,
if he didn't need it,
didn't need help,
he wouldn't,
he wouldn't have read wrote in.
And she's most likely saying she's into the three way to appease me and some
work twisted woman way.
Thanks for the advice.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Ah.
All right.
Here we go.
All right dude.
Um,
there's a bunch of stuff going on here.
first of all,
yet I can't really say that those were attempts when you tried to have a
threesome when your fiance was three months pregnant with a baby.
And then secondly,
uh,
the fact that you're attracted to the other yet,
you're not,
not attracted.
You had a crush on the other woman.
This,
there's rules to having a fucking threesome.
Uh,
you know,
you can't,
yeah,
you can't have feelings for the other woman.
And for the most part you can't climax with the other one.
That's also a problem.
Um,
from what I've heard,
I've never had one.
I never had.
I never had I,
you know what?
Twice in my life I could've had a threesome when I was younger,
but I was too fucking stupid to realize it was going on.
I just remember seeing that going,
like,
why,
when her girlfriend leave,
I'm trying to get laid here.
Then another time I was working in buffalo and these girls just put it on the
table.
They put it on table.
They basically said we're like a coalition.
I remember they used that word and one was hot and the other one looked like a
three story brownstone.
She was a fuck.
She like a building.
She was looking at the grenade.
She know she was like six,
three.
There was a guy used to play for fucking the Portland Trailblazers.
A duck worth.
That's what she looked like with the vagina.
And I was just,
I,
you know,
I never had,
you know what,
I never had that ability.
I never had that ability to just bang something that I wasn't attracted to.
It was just always disgusting to me.
So there you go.
So,
from what I've heard,
sir,
I am not speaking from a,
a,
a place of experience here,
but,
um,
I will tell you this,
if you're going to have a fucking threesome,
I wouldn't do it with someone who you're in a relationship with.
I don't think the relationship is ever the fucking same.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
it's just,
it's just a,
it's a weird
thanks.
Well,
I think they,
the issue that he's having with his,
his wife now
fiance,
he's just Marriner cause he knocked her up.
Um,
Jesus,
um,
is that she talks about wanting to be with women but is not acting on it.
But a lot of times,
you know,
people have these sexual fantasies and they're just meant to be fantasy.
Yeah.
They're not really necessarily going to be a reality.
Like just because you,
you know,
in your mind's eye or like,
Ooh,
that would be interesting.
It doesn't mean that you're actually going to go through,
like a lot of women have the gang bangers fantasy.
That doesn't mean they're going to go into a fucking loading dock and lay down
and be like,
who wants it?
All right.
Sorry,
I have male.
I have to get to the point
here.
Sure.
You have female listeners to,
you know,
um,
yeah,
so that doesn't necessarily mean that she's actually going to want to do it.
And your methods of trying to go about it are just so off the mark.
It's like laughable.
You know I wanted to have a threesome with you.
Alright.
Yup.
Which I do.
I don't,
I do in my head,
but I don't,
I don't want to do it because it's going to fuck everything up.
You really think so?
Yes.
It's going to be fucking weird.
It's going to be weird.
It's,
you know what it is the,
you fucking,
you cross too many,
you open too many Pandora's box,
whatever the fucking expression is.
You never come back.
You don't come back.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it's like you have to start over again.
You'd have to,
yeah,
I dunno.
You know,
it's like we were talking about Madonna,
Madonna when they were playing.
Like that was another thing too,
to add to the gayness,
to that bar.
They were playing Madonna videos and you were talking about her getting fucking
divorced.
He have his and helped her taste in men.
How she likes those.
Uh,
I was saying like,
when she wants a husband,
she goes for like that the Alpha male white guy,
you know,
a usually very like a macho strong man.
But then when she has her lovers,
that's when she has a 20 something year old Latino boy that no one's ever heard
of her little boy toy.
So here's the thing,
this girl is sold out fucking Madison Square Garden.
She's already done the fucking astronaut tour.
You know the astronauts that go around the fucking world,
they see how beautiful it is and then they start crying at a stop light.
You don't see too much.
It's the same thing with her if she's seen too much.
So if there's no way she's ever going to be able to keep a marriage going,
because at any moment as,
as she has to sit there and be unselfish and listen to this fucking square
headed white guy that she likes,
she wants to do like swear headed white guys.
Right?
So it's the guy's going like you not fucking giving me what I need at any
moment.
She can pull the rip cord,
still sell out Madison Square Garden and then go bang some fucking stud it
fetish guy.
If I had those options near you,
think I'd be listening to you at any point.
I could go in and fucking trade your acid for some fucking 22 year old and I
just start blowing me immediately.
Please.
I'd be out of here in a second,
ma'am.
Right.
I'd like to see you try it anyway.
Ah,
the worst shit.
Talking of every card Yas,
they,
I'd like to say you try it.
Why I Yada.
Yeah.
Why don't you let your Max,
why don't you stop having a jerk tone to this guy and help him out.
I was,
well,
I was going to say,
why don't you let your,
the person that you are in the relationship with that,
why don't you let her lead the way on this?
Because now you're just becoming like that advice.
That's guy that's putting all this pressure on her.
Just let her just let her open the door to it if she wants to.
If not,
leave it alone.
There's no need to keep pushing it.
This is what you do.
This is what that bad advice again,
because you don't know what you're talking about.
Yes,
I do know what I'm talking about.
You know a lot of people value my advice.
Here's the,
I have self esteem and I like myself.
That's right.
Hi,
this is the deal.
All right.
Fuck this.
You want this to happen,
sir.
This is what you gotta do.
All right.
If you will.
If you listened to Nia and you let her lead the way,
it's never going to happen.
Okay?
Because she's not going to act on it the next time you find someone who finds
you guys attractive as a couple,
do not tell you fucking fiance about it.
All right?
You tell the girl that's into it.
Listen,
you got to fucking make it look natural.
SORTA coerce her into it and that type of thing.
He just make it seem like it's natural.
She goers,
you go up to the bar and they just make it seem like it happened naturally and
then you never tell her the fucking secret and then that's it.
That's how you do it.
Because she's not going to take the lead.
And this guy is all fucking knees and elbows.
She was pregnant and I had a crush on the other girl.
What?
Gibbs?
Yeah,
no,
just the next time that there's a girl that's fucking interested in you as a
couple,
don't tell your wife about it.
And then go up there and just have her fucking strike up a conversation and just
say,
listen,
do not flirt with me at all.
Just flirt with her and get her fucking motor running.
And then maybe it'll go down.
And then what you want to do is try to start the kissing there at the bar.
It's actually not bad at rice.
Thank you.
See that's how you do it.
Because this,
I'm telling you,
it's not going to happen.
She's like,
I like,
if I get scared,
it's not going to happen.
So you gotta you gotta make it seem like it's natural.
Yeah.
That's how you do it.
You got to get sneaky there,
sir.
That's what I just advocated.
Fair enough.
Look at that,
Huh?
Every once in a while she agrees with me.
All right,
let's go on to fat Gi function.
I felt I wanted to let you know that people hate fat people to,
I want it to send it and
use some thoughts.
Not Too many from a considerate citizen of Fat America.
Yeah.
I've noticed that since I went off on the fat guy on the,
on the airplane.
Uh,
I've,
I've had fat people,
just tall people,
general goal.
I try to be real considerate of how big I am.
I try to make sure I get an aisle seat.
I leaned out in the aisle.
You shouldn't have to deal with that.
And it actually,
you know what's great about this now?
I can't really make fun of fatties anymore.
No one that's so many them are,
they seem like decent people.
I'll fucking one kind of a backhanded compliment was that,
you know,
I thought they were all pieces is shit,
but it turns out most of them are.
Most of them are right.
All right,
here we go.
He says,
I'm a big fat guy.
I'm usually the fattest guy in the room no matter where I go.
Uh,
do you get intimidated when,
when you're not the fattest guy,
you know,
sort of like the toughest guy in town,
all of a sudden goes to another town,
realizes that somebody can kick his ass and his whole world crumbles.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
my whole family's fat and I've been fat since I've been born.
Uh,
not to make any excuses.
I'm just naturally predisposed to it.
And I eat like a typical middle American,
uh,
Middle American,
not vegetarian,
but not 24,
seven beer and broths either.
Anyway,
I'm fat and I just wanted to let you know that not,
not all of us fatties or inconsiderate assholes.
The stereotype of the jolly fat man has been replaced by the selfish asshole
who's fat.
Uh,
when I fly,
which isn't frequently,
I buy two seats.
Nice.
My sister is with me.
We by a row of three and always bring along our own seat belt extenders.
Yes,
they sell them.
Okay.
This is,
uh,
this is hilarious and fucking sad all at the same time.
Uh,
the plane only carries two to three extenders and you never want to be the guy
who holds up the plane because you can't buckle or worse.
Get kicked off that Jesus has got to be embarrassing.
Oh my God,
this is,
this guy's killing me right here.
This guy is,
this is a brilliant email.
He's going to make me never make fun of fatties again.
I'm actually,
he's now,
he's bringing me into their world.
He goes,
those things costs $80,
but it's worth $80 to avoid public embarrassment.
Right?
Absolutely.
If they told me to tone down the color of my hair,
I would buy a fucking swimming cap rather than have them stop the flight.
Just so you know,
fat people like me don't get to buy clothes in the same stores as normal people.
Yes,
I did know that.
The selection slash style suck and they cost more.
We pay more for bigger cars,
extra plane tickets,
and bigger clothes among other things.
I haven't done the math,
but I figured we burned through through furniture faster.
Two
it's the price we pay for the life we lead.
Even if it's not a conscious choice.
Believe me,
no one wants to be fat,
but that's the cost of doing business.
This guy's fucking hilarious.
Just like how they are added,
there are added costs of being a woman,
bras,
makeup,
pills,
et Cetera,
or gay or being gay.
He writes question mark,
chaps,
Lube,
I dunno,
or a parent or a paraplegic or whatever.
Not that it's a disability.
Uh,
it's just our lot in life,
but you know what accepted it.
I live my life accordingly.
I'm not an asshole who imposes on others.
I stayed in the back of any pack,
make sure no one will ever have to walk or sit behind me when I can help it.
It's the fat guy.
Funkshway how do you,
how do you dislike this guy?
When I enter a room or a situation,
I always ask where do I fit in?
Literally and figuratively,
whenever I have to eat lunch with my work group,
about 20 people and we're seated at a long table.
I never sit between the table in the wall and I usually sit at the end.
No.
Why?
I don't want,
I want to make as few people uncomfortable as possible.
Uh,
I don't want anyone to have to squeeze behind me to get out and sitting between
two people just pisses them both off or so.
I assume Jesus Christ,
this guy's like a fat Gandy.
Um,
when I have to Carpool with a group,
it helps to drive or have shotgun because then I'm not squeezing the other
people in the back seat.
The thing that makes me hate fat people,
capital letters,
hate fat people,
is that they don't seem to realize that they're fat.
They are impulsive and selfish and don't seem to consider that what a normal guy
eats.
That when a normal guy eats a giant Turkey leg at Disneyland,
it's a,
it's a lame and kind of funny,
oh,
it's layman kind of funny.
But when a fat guy does it,
it's disgusting.
Or maybe they just got fat and haven't figured it out.
Hey,
fatty,
don't sit there because now everyone has to squeeze past you.
I like this guy.
He's trashing fat people know,
or Hey,
don't act like you're entitled to that to put your arm around your airplane seat
mate,
because it makes you more comfortable for you.
It makes it more comfortable for you.
You asshole.
He just keeps going here.
Or Hey,
if you got to eat in public,
don't smear barbecue sauce all over your face at the church picnic or written
more than two donuts in a sitting parentheses airport.
And you know what?
When I swim in public,
rarely I keep my shirt on until the second before I get in the pool.
I don't ride the elevator from my hotel room and walked down the hall to the
Hampton Inn pool shirtless because I'm a fat fuck and no one wants to see that.
I used to swim with my shirt on,
but somehow that's even worse.
Uh,
anyways,
for what it's worth,
have a good week.
Thank for the hilarity.
Ah,
you know what,
that guys,
all right.
You know what?
I bet there's more people like that then.
Then there's not.
So maybe I ought to lay off the fatties for half a second.
I'm just doing this just to fucking,
you know,
this is what this podcast is.
It's like a smoker and every once in a while you just,
you gotta,
you gotta I don't even know what you gotta do.
You gotta throw a little wet wood in there.
That's what that was.
I think I'm gonna leave the fatties alone.
I think they were actually really considering,
I think I was wrong about it
the entire time.
I have been happy.
All right.
I flew into lax,
Los Angeles International Airport,
that for some reason,
if you go beyond Colorado,
you just can't get a fucking direct flight anywhere.
I don't,
I don't get it.
When I was in New York City,
I could fly to all these places directly.
Maybe it's cause I was in New York and it was only an hour and a half away.
Okay.
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
It just doesn't seem like he can fly anyway.
So anyways,
I've got to fly to La,
to Phoenix,
Phoenix to Columbus,
all right.
On us.
So I get on the plane and there's two empty seats next to me and it's getting
close to the point where they're going to close the door to the plane and I'm
like excited.
Like Holy Shit,
I'm going to have this whole fucking road in myself.
Just be nice.
I could stretch out a little bit.
Take my carry on,
stick it under the other chair.
This is going to be great.
Right before the close the door,
low and behold,
this fat tub of shit gets on the fucking plate.
All right?
And I'm thinking,
Oh God,
not me,
please for the love of God.
Don't pick my row.
You don't want to do that shit.
You just fucking willing to guide to sit down as he waddles his fat ass down the
fucking aisle,
it's him in his fucking lady,
right?
So he fucking comes all the way up,
comes to my row,
and he's just standing there and I'm hoping he's just standing there because
he's putting his stuff in the overhead compartment.
I can literally feel the fucking heat radiating off of his body from the 22
years of mistakes that he's putting his goddamn stomach.
All right,
and what is he doing?
Oh yeah,
I'm in that role.
I'll meet your role.
So I got to get up and what does he do?
His feet,
let's his fucking girls sit by the window and then he sits in the middle seat
and this fat fucking Tba fucking shit.
Okay.
This dude was so fat.
I was sitting behind his back fat.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
He was like fat and round.
It was like sitting next to a planet with a head,
you know,
it was like you could the roundness of this guy.
Okay,
so he's trying to be less fat.
God bless him.
So he crosses his arms when all it does is just causes fat lat to fucking bulge
out even more into my airspace that I fucking paid for
and sundry.
All I'm thinking is why the fuck did he take the window seat and then post up
against his girlfriend?
My shoulder was getting hot from his arm.
It was,
he was on me.
It was fucking guy was on me.
If I was claustrophobic,
they would've had to turn the plane around.
This is how much this guy was in my chair
and I'm thinking,
why the hell?
Why didn't you just take the fucking window seat?
You Fat,
fuck.
Have a little bit of fucking consideration.
Your tub of Shit.
Okay.
You know with your basketball shorts,
like you actually,
her played a goddamn day in your life.
It's fucking legs spread out.
Like he was going to give birth to a baby calf.
You know,
why don't you sit near the window?
You know?
I realized after awhile he didn't sit near the winner because he's so fucking
fat.
He can't,
he can't be sat by the window.
His other fat lat would a blown out the window.
We all would have got sucked out unless it's tough as shit.
Body fucking somehow got stuck in the fuselage,
which if you saw him
wouldn't,
wouldn't be be a possibility.
Unfucking believable and he's sitting there,
this is what kills me.
He's sitting there and he's,
he's biting his nails and I just want to be like,
dude,
do you ever stop eating?
Is there a moment and you'll,
you'll literally consuming yourself right now.
I know,
I know.
I know what you guys think.
Well,
hey bill,
why don't you fly first class?
Oh yeah.
Well,
hey,
why don't you go fuck yourself.
Hypothetical person who said that,
okay,
I understand.
I bought a coach seat.
I know what that means.
That means my fucking knees are going to be in my chest.
That means if I'm even slightly lean forward and the guy in front of me reclines
he's going to hit me in the head.
I understand that.
Okay,
I get it,
but that doesn't mean that this type of shit,
I shouldn't have to pay an extra couple of fucking grant,
uh,
or whatever,
1500 bucks.
So somebody else's Lard isn't in my lap.
I am full on 100% behind you having to buy two seats when you're on an airplane.
Okay?
I'm sorry.
You're fat.
Okay,
but you made your choices.
This is one of the things,
this is a good thing.
You got to buy two seats.
You got less money for cookies.
Maybe that'll be a goal.
Maybe that'll be your bottoming out,
but it's,
it's absolutely ridiculous that I have to say,
I literally leaning out into the fucking aisle.
My giant microwave oven head is out there and then I to deal with the stewardess
going,
Steve,
me skews.
We share.
Can you not sharing you share.
Please share.
Right.
I gotta watch him Houma.
I can't start yelling here.
I'm in a hotel room again.
I already got one strike against me.
They probably build a fucking file on me.
Um,
yeah,
I'm leaning out there.
That was,
this is the best part.
The food cart comes.
Okay.
They asked me what I,
you know,
they asked to do what he wants to drink.
He goes,
can I have a coke?
Can I have a coke?
I just want to be like,
dude,
how about a water?
How about a salad?
You trying to make yourself even fatter during the flight.
Do you know what that's sold is going to do?
Do you already distended fucking belly.
You already can't even put the fucking tray down.
He still couldn't put the tray down.
He tried.
He tried to put the train.
Oh my God,
this fucking guy.
I swear to God,
the thoughts.
I was thinking it was embarrassing.
I was sitting there thinking like,
you know,
I'm so glad this dude's going to die young.
Can you believe that?
I'm not happy in real life that that's going to happen,
but that's how fucking uncomfortable I was and that's how fucking mad I was at
this guy.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You got to buy two seats people,
he got to do it.
Okay.
I love when they try to leave the fucking arm up to,
I don't play that.
I fucking shave that ham right down.
Open a fucking dead right the fuck down
fucking city and making me uncomfortable and you,
you want to relax.
If I could,
I put my foot on your chest to make your belt even tighter.
If that's what I do to you cut off you circle your license or your legs,
maybe you'd get up and take a walk.
There's no excuse for it.
Yeah.
You know,
and I know this is probably coming off in sensitive,
but you know,
something had been a red head my whole life.
Nobody gives a shit we don't get,
we don't,
we're not considered handicapped capped.
We're not considered.
He kept,
this always happens when I scream all weekend.
We're not considered handicapped.
We don't get our own parking spaces.
These tubs is shit.
They getting their own parking spaces now,
making a shorter walk to the store,
making them even fatter.
The only positive thing I can say about this guy was he only went to Phoenix and
he didn't smell.
I got to give him that.
He didn't smell,
I don't know if he fucking jumped in a God damn pond,
you know,
killed 200 fish before he got onto the flight.
I don't know what he did,
but he didn't smell right.
Okay.
But I swear to God,
you know what?
You know what kills me is I ranted about this on the radio here in Columbus and
somebody called up the radio station set out.
I'm five,
eight 300 pounds,
and I love to fly.
I'm never listening to this radio station again.
Can you believe that this dude actually felt like he was the victim?
Okay.
You know,
that'd be like if some wife who got the shit kicked out of her,
ranted about her piece of shit for slapping the shit
out of her and then some guy calls up,
hey,
I got issues with women and I slapped the shit out of my wife and I'm never
listen to this radio station again.
You know,
give me a fucking break.
you know what you need to do?
Eat a salad,
go for a walk.
You don't have to put money down for it,
for the gym.
Just go for a walk.
It's actually easier to do cardio.
Okay.
When you're not at the gym,
cause we had to Jim,
at any point you can just get off.
Okay.
And walk a hundred yards to your car.
Your car is always a hundred yards away.
When you walk out your front door and you walk a mile away,
okay,
what are you going to just quit and lay down on the ground?
You've got to walk back.
There's two miles,
easy as two miles.
You all have a fucking deal
or our,
our be a tub of shit.
Be Fat that that's your right.
Okay.
But by two seats,
it's all I'm going to say.
All right.
Okay.
Do I wear short shorts shown off my milk?
White legs offending everybody's eyeballs?
No,
I don't.
I'm considerate.
I with the Jordan once they come down right off my little white.
Nice.
Um,
you're listening to the Monday morning podcast and yes,
it is insensitive.
It doesn't mean it's wrong.
I'm right.
I'm right on this one.
I'll fucking a fatties who listened to this podcast?
God bless you.
Have yourself a Sunday on a Monday,
right?
I understand it.
Your emotional leaders,
something fucking bad happened to you.
So food is your friend and then you go in there.
I get it,
I get it.
I want you to lose weight.
I want you to feel good about yourself.
But until you're at that weight,
well you're not,
you know,
spilling into my seat.
You got to buy two seats.
I shouldn't have to suffer because you ate all the cookies in the house.
That's not my fucking fault of Jesus.
Bill.
We got it.
I actually tweeted this week that fat people are the new secondhand smoking.
Hey,
you want to be fat?
Go outside.
[inaudible].